soit voilà c'est lors de notre second
débat débat de société volontairement
décalée de l'actualité du jour 40
minutes sur un thème pour l'analyser en
profondeur alors ce soit vous propose de
parler de la réindustrialisation de la
france enjeu stratégique réapparu avec
cette crise sanitaire mais quel est le
bilan du quinquennat macron première
réponse avec jonathan
en cinq ans emmanuel macron est il
parvenu à réindustrialiser la france au
gré de ses déplacements aux allures de
pré campagne électorale le président
veut en persuader les français est sur
le terrain il multiplie les annonces
comme ici à belfort sur le nucléaire je
souhaite que si je perds 2 soit
construit et que nous lancions les
études sur la construction de huit le
pr2 additionnel au sénat ces annonces
ont fait bondir notamment la gauche qui
dénonce de belles promesses de fin de
quinquennat annoncé à cinq semaines de
la fin du mandat qu'on va lancer une
dizaine de paires qui ne sont réalisés
qu'en 2035 ou 2040 au mieux ce n'est pas
sérieux mais monsieur macron aujourd'hui
et dans la surenchère je le regrette
chantre de la start up nation en début
de mandat le président de la république
a opéré un virage à 180 degrés avec la
crise du coc vide révélatrice de
profondes lacunes françaises notamment
dans l'industrie pharmaceutique et ça a
été un virage important parce que le
président de la république a décidé la
de taper un grand coup de lance
effectivement à un moment où est bien
notre économie vaciller un plan de
relance économique important industriel
de souveraineté emmanuel macron c'est
donc engouffré dans la brèche en sortant
le carnet de chèques pour
réindustrialiser le pays plan de relance
à 100 milliards d'euros en septembre
2020 puis un an plus tard le plan france
2030 et ses 34 milliards intégré au
budget via un seul et unique amendement
de l'amateurisme pour certains élus eler
pa ça me laisse à penser que les
arbitrages n'étaient pas vraiment
finaliser quand l' amendement a été
déposé on à 10,34 milliards on a dit des
grandes lignes mais ensuite concrètement
où ces milliards vers quelles actions
ils sont fléchés tout ça restait encore
à définir si la méthode du gouvernement
divise la majorité présidentielle met en
avant des chiffres selon la ministre de
l'industrie agnès pannier rue nash et
127 sites industriels ont été recréés
entre 2016 et 2021 sur le territoire
comment la france peut-elle enrayer son
déclin industriel walla thème de notre
débat j'accueille anaïs se voit gillis
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes docteur en
géographie chercheuse associée à l'iae
de poitiers cole universitaire de
management auteur de vers la renaissance
industriel c'est aux éditions marie b
guillaume 15 marion bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue députés les oem d'eure-et-loir
vous avez présidé une commission
denquête à l'assemblée nationale sur ce
thème de la réindustrialisation ou d
industrialisation ça dépend de quel côté
on regarde le phénomène à nicolas
baverez bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes historien économiste essayiste
votre dernier livre reconstruction au
pluriel c'est aux éditions de
l'observatoire j'accueille également en
duplex eric lombard bon soit avec
lombard le directeur général de la
caisse des dépôts c'est quand même le
premier pôle financier public français
vous publiez au coeur de la finance
utile à quoi sert votre épargne c'est
aux éditions là aussi de l'observatoire
bienvenue à vous laetitia cru pas
évidemment est resté à mes côtés on
vient de voir je vais commencer par ça
peut-être le bilan du quinquennat
matheron macron viens de voir le sujet
de jonathan dû plier vous fait quel
bilan vous anaïs vosges et nice
le bilan de la réindustrialisation alors
sur la réindustrialisation c'est trop
tôt encore pour tirer un tire un bilan
moi ce que je trouve très important de
rappeler ses consorts d'un sigle 30 à 40
ans tu d industrialisation et qu on est
en train de prendre un virage réellement
depuis mars 2020 sur des actions pour
réindustrialiser la france et donc on ne
va pas pouvoir juger de la réalité des
actions même si on a des éléments
positifs sur un solde positif de
créations du sinn sur des sols de
création d'emplois etc on ne va pas
pouvoir mesurer tout de suite l'impact
rés des mesures qui ont été prises et
l'enjeu numéro un qu'on a on a tendance
à oublier parce qu'on a aussi des
éléments négatifs ainsi regard la
balance commerciale s'est vraiment
travailler la re construction dit qu'au
système productif c'est se dire ce qui
est intéressant c'est une usine et
l'écosystème de sous traitants qu'on va
avoir autour parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on va créer à la fois de l'emploi
durable et surtout qu'on va répondre à
des enjeux de souveraineté et de
rééquilibrage dans la balance
commerciale on a aussi des gros sujets
trop str de structuration de la demande
pour des produits français à la fois en
interne mais aussi en externe mais tout
ça va prendre du temps avant de se
matérialiser
et contrairement à ce qui a été dit moi
je pense que quand on a des annonces
qui prennent des engagements sur le
temps long c'est important parce que le
temps industriel c'est quelque chose
qu'ils devaient décorer les du temps
politique et si on ne pense pas une
stratégie industrielle qui se projette
la france dans les 20 30 ou 40
prochaines années avec les déploiements
d'infrastructures que ça sous-entend
puisqu'à partir du moment où on dit on
va développer des mobilités reposant sur
l'électricité ou d'hydrogène ça veut
dire qu'il faut produire de
l'électricité audi érogènes donc il faut
des moyens et des infrastructures pour
cela il ya un choix majeur c est ce qu
on veut rien dû se réalise la filière
nucléaire est ce qu'on lui redonne du
souffle ou est ce qu'on met tout le
paquet par exemple sur le les énergies
renouvelables ça fait partie des choix
effectivement qui nous engage pour très
longtemps mais même même si vous êtes
sur des énergies renouvelables vous êtes
quand même sur des temps long tu sais
quand on met des éoliennes on placerait
la presse quel que soit le choix ça nous
engage sur ce genre des décennies
exactement nicolas baverez effectivement
on peut on peut voir différents chiffres
vous vous y faisiez allusion bilan 2021
sur les créations de du in et les
fermetures cinquante trois ouvertures de
sites 24 fermetures de sites donc là on
peut se dire bon bah c'est on a inversé
un peu la tendance et puis si on regarde
la balance commerciale quand même un bon
indicateur là au contraire on va on va
être désespéré non mais ce qui vient
d'être dit par anaïs ou emily c'est tout
à fait juste c'est à dire que en matière
d'industrie l'industrie par principe
c'est du temps long donc de toute
manière cette année 2021 elle est très
singulière puisque on a fait moins 8 ans
8 puces 7 et c'est pas s'en mêler et par
ailleurs la désindustrialisation elle ne
date pas de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron on a perdu deux millions et demi
d'emplois sur 25 ans et l'industrie est
passé de 24 à 10 % du pib au cours de la
même période
et ce qui est important c'est que ce
qu'on disait mais je crois que ce qui
s'est passé dans ce quinquennat en
réalité c'est la prise de conscience
c'est à dire qu'on était un certain
nombre à dire depuis longtemps que
l'industrie c'était important parce que
c'était évidemment de l'activité mais
c'est de l'emploi à haute valeur ajoutée
et plutôt avec de bons salaires c'est de
la recherche et de l'innovation
et ce sont les exportations et il s'est
passé je pense deux choses importantes
premièrement avec
l'épidémie de kovy d' alors qu'on
pensait avoir une industrie de santé
très forte et notamment les champions
des vaccins à rosette aperçu que en
matière d'industrie de recherche alors
que la rn messager est une invention de
pasteur en 1961 mais où ça n'était plus
nulle part en tout cas en france et
l'autre chose c'est que ce fameux
déficit de 85 milliards d'euros qui est
quand même très lourd et qui va être
sans doute de 95 ou plus cette année
pour presque 4% du pib il est dû à
l'effondrement industriel quand on
regarde ce qui se passe est évidemment
il ya une composante prix de l'énergie
mais le gros c'est la chute de
l'industrie donc il ya cette prise de
conscience que il faut vraiment si on
veut arriver à re rééquilibrer notre
modèle économique du côté de la
production il ya un énorme à feu est
énorme un énorme effort à faire sur
l'industrie et ensuite ce qui est vrai
alors c'est la limite de ces plans comme
il a été dit parce que des plans pour
réindustrialiser on en a fait quasiment
tous les deux ou trois ans depuis
c'est pas le premier on avait déjà le
déjà sous nicolas sarkozy il ya eu
plusieurs plans et on voit que ça a
continué donc quel est le problème il ya
deux problèmes
on a toujours un problème de
compétitivité prix absolument majeur est
par ailleurs on n'a pas réglé notre
problème de spécialisation donc les
produits industriels français en moyenne
pour aller très vite son très cher pour
une qualité médiocre on y revient on y
reviendra reviendra la chose importante
et je rejoins ce qui a été dit encore
c'est que derrière les plans pourquoi ça
marche pas parce que on ne traite pas ce
qu'il ya derrière c'est à dire que oui
il faut un état entrepreneur mais pour
qu'une filière démarre il faut avoir
réfléchi à quels sont les opérateurs
quelles sont les compétences si on les a
pas ou est ce qu'on va les chercher à
les oublier parce que tout le monde va
prendre la parole dans ce débat on a 40
minutes mais quand même guillaume
kasparian dans la porte 1 le mans terre
que vous aviez copiloté vous disiez il
faut réconcilier les français avec
l'industrie moi ça m'a surpris on il y
avait un désamour pour l'industrie en
france force est de constater que
pendant des décennies la politique
industrielle et l'industrie n'a pas été
au coeur du discours politique pendant
des décennies les français mais plus
leur industrie non mais c'est il ya eu
des courants de pensée il ya de ça
quelques années qui parlait de modèles
fabless c'est à dire d'une économie qui
serait uniquement du tertiaire du
service avec de la production
complètement optimisé à l'autre bout du
monde est une sorte d' optimisation qui
ferait qu on produirait plus rien en
france on inventerait des choses mais
ensuite on délocaliserait la production
ailleurs ce courant a été même assumé il
ya eu des grands dirigeants qui ont
assumé ce propos la qui était entier
industrie et qui du coup a fait
d'écouler un certain nombre de de
politique et qui n'était pas favorable à
l'industrie et puis avait aussi pendant
des années deservant des virages gauche
dvg virage droite qui faisait que la
politique fiscale qui contribue à la
compétitivité que monsieur base rays a
rappelé n'était pas constante et vous
aviez des industriels qui voyait la
compétitivité se dégrader par rapport à
nos voisins avec des hausses d'impôts
parfois mener y compris par la droite
qui en réalité venait atteindre la
compétitivité de notre industrie ce
quinquennat a été effectivement celui de
la prise de conscience que l'industrie
devait être au coeur de notre économie
qui ne pouvait pas y avoir d'économie
forte sans industrie forte et il a été
celui de l'addition me pour ça non parce
que je le redis des réformes de
structure ont été menées dès le début du
mandat je pourrais vous parler de la
réforme du code du travail plus personne
n'en parle aujourd'hui mais à l'époque
l'industriel lui disais c'est compliqué
le code du travail on a du mal à se
développer on a une question autour des
prud'hommes et c'est à la première
mesure qui a été mise en place et une
réforme de structure se sont c'est une
réforme du code du travail pourrait
parler de la loi pacte la loi pacte qui
a été une mesure de simplification
elle a permis oui mais sauf que les
ordonnances travail les cinq ordonnances
travail c'est la première loi du
quinquennat qu'on a voté on nous l'a
suffisamment d'ailleurs reproché en nous
expliquant qu'on était en train de
déconstruire le code du travail la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
industriels aujourd'hui ils nous disent
que la politique fiscale de réformes de
structure qui a été mené est une
politique qui permet de faire revenir
dans le free et nous avons des résultats
quand je dis nous c'est notre pays on
peut se réjouir aujourd'hui qu'on recrée
à nouveau de l'emploi industriel qu'on
recrée des sites industriels qu'on à
arrêter cette hémorragie pendant des
décennies qui avaient grevé notre
industrie allez je me tourne vers eric
lombard la caisse des dépôts eric
lombard acteurs majeurs de l'économie
française y a
je sais pas si je vous laisse vous
dressez toutes les activités moi je vais
le faire rapidement il ya la banque des
territoires et la gestion d'actifs de
100 milliards d'euros sous gestion les
politiques sociales avec la gestion des
retraites d'un français sur cinq vous
financez où vous construisez des
logements sans oublier les partenariats
avec le groupe la poste ou encore bpi
france on on parle quoi de souveraineté
économique dans ce débat autour de la
réindustrialisation est ce que c'est
votre raison d'être ça
alors notre raison d'être c'est de
contribuer au bon développement du pays
dans toutes ses dimensions moi je devais
revenir sur ce débat sur sur l'industrie
parce que si on prend une vision longue
il ya eu pendant trente ans quelque
chose qui est très surprenant c'est un
véritable abandon de notre industrie
d'abord don parce que vous vous souvenez
de ce patron d'entreprise qui parlait
d'une entreprise sans usine et on a
abandonné notre industrie ben au travers
de plusieurs scieries de gouvernement ce
n'était pas un sujet à gauche droite
c'est vraiment un abandon qui a été fait
successivement à la gauche et 1 à droite
quand elle est arrivée au pouvoir il ya
eu à en voir un reversement ces
dernières années et en tant qu'opérateur
nous on en voit les effets et ce
reversement en réalité les très
puissants
parce que pour donner un exemple il ya
cinq ans les jeunes s'y lancer une
entreprise il en scène start-up
digitales sur internet aujourd'hui ce
qui est passionnant c'est que les jeunes
s'y lancent une affaire c'est une
affaire industrielle et c'est une
affaire industrielle qui veulent monter
sur nos territoires et sur lequel il ya
tout un tas de systèmes qui peut leur
permettre de le faire soit donner un
exemple très concret il ya des jeunes
qui sont rencontrés comme souvent dans
les startups à l'université qui était
spécialiste d'insectes sont des
passionnés ils ont développé dans le
doubs un démonstrateur sur la
fabrication de farine nominal à partir
d'insectes et puis on a inauguré il ya
un an près d'amiens une usine verticale
silva pas économisé beaucoup de terrain
puisque au lieu d'avoir des shows où
l'agriculture pour nourrir les poissons
ou le détail eh bien ces insectes les
scarabées molitor vont être traitées
pour cette alimentation
et ce processus d'approbation suis sûr
que ça va réussir à se développer et ils
vont le faire en france et non seulement
ils vont faire un modèle social français
dont vous entendez qu'il était coûteux
mais maintenant mieux c'est à dire que
le salaire minimum dans cette usine sera
supérieure au smic ils vont donner des
avantages sociaux supérieurs parce que
propose le code du travail donc c'est un
projet
d'entrepreneurs et c'est aussi un projet
social d'ailleurs comme si amiens ils
vont donner priorité à l'embauché ou
personnes qui ont été licenciées dans
les usines de wor poule donc on voit
bien la cohérence de cette chose là un
autre exemple passionnant dans la meuse
dans la meuse un entrepreneur qui va
construire une usine pour faire d'ériger
qui vont faire les carences les
carrosseries des automobiles de demain
touristes et les pièces d'aluminium et
les pièces de composites et comme il a
un brevet mondial en plus probablement
cette usine sera musique européenne des
puits y aura une filiale en amérique
latine une autre filiale en asie donc on
voit bien il ya une centaine aujourd'hui
une centaine de projets industriels sur
notre territoire qui sont en train de se
développer d'arrivée pour lequel
d'ailleurs avec les élus locaux on a mis
en place des friches il ya une grande
friche près de chalon-sur-saône la
friche kodak qui est prête à
d'équipements industriels donc les
entrepreneurs qui arrive on les aide il
ya un accompagnement de tout
l'écosystème pour jets industrialisés
notre pays c'est intéressant parce qu'on
parle de réindustralisation on va on va
s'appuyer aussi sur ce plan france 2030
plan de 30 milliards d'euros investis
sur cinq ans avec les secteurs annoncé
hydrogène vers nucléaire véhicules
propres robotique biomédicaments et et
composants c'est un axe évidemment de
communication fort du président la
république depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
on l'écouté à saint-etienne il rendait
visite à un groupe qui s'appelle si des
années l'entreprise s'appelle si des
années c'était le 25 octobre dernier
emmanuel macron
on pourra réindustrialiser la france
grâce aux transformations auxquelles
vous contribuez on va pas
réindustrialiser la france en
redéveloppant l'industrie qu'on
connaissait il ya 20 ans ou 30 ans la
nostalgie n'est pas bonne conseillère la
nostalgie n'est pas bonne conseillère je
trouve ça intéressant
un évangéliste parce que on ré industrie
ça veut pas dire qu'on recrée les
industries d'avant quoi alors ou est-ce
que c'est plus compliqué c'est plus
compliqué que ça et que quand on dit ça
on induit des billets c'est à dire
l'industrie quand pourra arriver un bien
que ce soit une automobile
des médicaments ou autres on a
différentes étapes dans la chaîne de
valeur et on a différents intrants aux
différentes étapes de la chaîne de
valeur et on a un certain nombre
d'atteintes rang qui vont être des
matières telles que l'acier l'aluminium
sur lequel on a un avantage compétitif
puisque on a une électricité d un mix
énergétique déjà décarbonés par rapport
à d'autres grosses mutuelles et quand on
dit on va pas refaire comme avant oui on
va pas refaire des usines et dix mille
salariés nous est une évidence on va
avoir des usines plus compactes avec
plus automatisés ont provoqué ce qui
pose quand même des questions aussi sur
la place qu'on offre en terme d'emploi
aux personnes peu qualifiées
puisqu'avant elle pouvait intégrer aussi
des usines et avoir des parcours et des
progressions au sein des entreprises et
donc faire attention au mythe de la
société qui ne serait que pour les
personnes qualifiées quelle quelle
option offre pour pour les autres
concitoyens l'autre chose c'est que
quand on dit ça on oublie ses matières
on oublie qu on a besoin de continuer à
produire de l'acier en france on a
besoin de réfléchir et ce qu'il faudrait
faire une usine de production de la
lutte de magnésium sur le territoire
français ou européens et on se dit que
finalement tout ça on n'a pas besoin et
on est encore dans un dans un quelque
chose qui traduit un manque de culture
industrielle l'industrie c'est des
phénomènes complexes et d'hydrogène on
va pas le produire par magie les hôtes
des voitures de demain on va pas les
produire par magie et à travers ça eh
ben on oublie aussi qu'on a des
compétences à repositionner et je pense
notamment et je vais les toits important
d'en parler on va avoir des
transformations très importantes à venir
notamment dans le secteur de
l'automobile et on a des sous traitants
qui vont être extrêmement touchés donc
ça appelle déjà 1 à solidarité dont on
est capable de faire preuve au sein des
filières donc c'est aussi une question
un peu de responsabilité nationale à un
moment des grands donneurs d'ordre parce
que notre écosystème productif est comme
ça et qu'on a des grands donneurs
d'ordre qui tire des filières et la
deuxième chose c'est comment est ce
qu'on parle de ses compétences
existantes pour les repositionner vers
les métiers c'est un bon exemple
l'industrie automobile nicolas baverez
ce parce que la transformation vers le
tout électrique est quand même brutal il
ya peu de secteurs qui ont connu une
transformation aussi rapide est ce
qu'elle sera forcément destructrices
d'emploi
réponse
elle va on détruire elle va en créer
aussi mais le solde net sera un solde
négatif parce que le a priori le
électrique demandera beaucoup moins de
également de d'entretien mais mais il
donc si on généralise est ce que l'art
et industrie les c'est dur à dire à
réalisation effectivement elle peut
s'adresser à tous les types d'emplois
même les emplois les moins qualifiés
alors ce qui a été dit est aussi juste
c'est à dire que si vous voulez pourquoi
est ce que l'industrie permet
normalement de pays mieux passer parce
que il ya le levier du capital et donc
il ya une productivité qui est qui est
effectivement supérieure mais ce qui a
été dit tout à fait juste c'est à dire
que il faut pas en déduire que les aimer
les métiers où les produits de demain
sont complètement con qu'on abandonne et
qu'on fait table rase je vous donne un
exemple
une de nos filières d'excellence qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui de manière
extraordinaire c'est le luxe le luxe
vous vendez des chaussures des vêtements
des sacs à main avec a été si les gens
sont prêts à payer très cher c'est
précisément parce qu'on utilise des
techniques traditionnelles françaises
c'est ce que font nos grandes aux grands
groupes du luxe donc il faut faire
attention à l'esprit de système c'est à
dire que on peut tout à fait avoir une
industrie très performante dans des
métiers qui sont traditionnelles donc ce
qui est important c'est d'avoir un
produit qui soit compétitif et avec des
coûts qu'ils soient d'où le travail à
faire comme on l'a dit à des problèmes
de ce qui a été montré par le conseil de
la compétitivité aujourd'hui ça montre à
quel point l'éducation est quelque chose
de très important c'est que on a la
moitié des postes aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont occupés dans le secteur privé par
des gens qui n'ont pas les compétences
pour les tenir à cause d'un déficit de
formation donc on voit qu'il faut
investir puissamment là dedans on a un
problème également 2
d'orientation
2d de l'epargne on a derrière aux cibles
un problème fiscal il ya une partie qui
a été fait sur les impôts de production
c'est sûr qu'il faut aller un peu plus
loin donc vous voyez il faut travailler
sur tous les facteurs de production le
travail le capital l'innovation
l'environnement et ensuite on peut tout
à fait y arriver c'est ce que je
voudrais quand même rappeler pour dire
c'est que d'abord il ya d'autres pays
qui sont arrivés et ensuite que si vous
regardez le le drame qui a eu lieu par
exemple sur le notamment en lorraine
avec la destruction de la sidérurgie et
du textile lorrain à partir des années
70 on s'aperçoit qu'il ya eu des plans
de réindustrialisation à l'époque et que
certains ont bien marché et
qu'aujourd'hui on a encore des
entreprises pour le coup industriel
puissante qui sont toujours performant
ça peut marcher qui date de ces plans
d'eau ça peut marcher je voudrais
condition d'avoir un partenariat mais ce
que je disais un partenariat pour le
coup de moderne entre l'état et les
entreprises et 6 1 en deux ou en quatre
variants des critiques qui est fait au
plan france 2030 c'est que finalement il
ya là une occasion de flécher cet
investissement public vert
la transition écologique vers les
industries décarbonés que ça n'a pas été
suffisamment fait qu'est ce que
reconnaît à sa non je ne crois pas là on
parlait de l'automobile par exemple est
un très bon exemple sur la transition
écologique puisqu'il ya une mutation
très très importante du secteur qu'on a
d'ailleurs observé en commission d'
enquête en interrogeant tous les acteurs
avec une situation qui est extrêmement
complexe pour énormément de sous
traitants aujourd'hui vous avez des
dizaines de milliers de salariés
aujourd'hui en france qui sont concernés
par cette transition du moteur thermique
vers le moteur électrique avec des
salariés qui sont durement touchés avec
cette transition écologique qui se fait
qu'on accompagne qu'on accélère qu'il va
falloir
transformer et trouver les compétences
nécessaires mais c'est quand même
quelque chose de très dur à vivre sur le
terrain il faut en avoir conscience puis
un autre facteur aussi sur l'automobile
puisque vous l'avez citer que c'était
l'objet c'était un des objets denquête
que nous avions c'est la relation
exécrable en ce moment entre les sous
traitants et les donneurs d'ordre avec
des sous-traitants qui nous disent on
nous demande des baisses de quantité des
stocks qui sont déportés des gains de
productivité dans les années qui
viennent et un refus de certains
constructeurs d'accepter les hausses de
prix qui les met dans une situation
absolument dramatique et une prise de
conscience sur l'approvisionnement et le
made in france qui est très limité chez
certains constructeurs y compris des
constructeurs français si bien que dans
le secteur automobile en est dans une
situation qui est extrêmement difficile
qui est dû en grande partie à la
transition écologique que l'on
accompagne sur lequel on met des
investissements massifs près vous
l'avais dit il ya des secteurs qui sont
aussi en transition écologique qui sont
des vrais fleuron de la france je pense
au luxe pensées à la cosmétique je pense
à la beauté qui sont des secteurs en
plus exportateurs puisque tout à l'heure
vous parlez de la balance commerciale il
trouve que la cosmétique et la beauté ce
sont des secteurs qui exportent
massivement à l'étranger et qui relève
la balance commerciale il faut s'appuyer
sur les secteurs en pointe en force qui
sont exportateurs sur lequel on est
compétitif à la fois sur le prix mais
aussi sur la qualité puis sur la marque
france pour pouvoir ensuite exportés
largement il relevé la balance
commerciale je reste sur cette idée de
de favoriser finalement la transition
écologique et l'industrie décarbonés
eric lombard c c'est l'un des thèmes de
votre livre la finance utile d'ailleurs
il ya beaucoup d'établissements
bancaires qui se retire progressivement
des industries carbonnaise que vous
diriez que c'est une tendance lourde
oui ça c'est évidemment une obligation
parce que si le taux de carbone de
l'économie continue aux îles où il est
on aura un problème de soutenabilité
notamment d'une autre modèle mais de la
vie tout court et je voudrais revenir
justement sur le rôle de l'industrie
dans la décarbonation et de l'art et
l'implantation d'industries en fait ce
qui est important en matière
industrielle c'est pas tant les
émissions de co2 que l'empreinte carbone
d'un processus or l'empreinte carbone
d'une usine ou apprendre par exemple les
indh vercors qui a décidé de s'installer
à dunkerque pour faire des batteries qui
va prendre de l'énergie à partir du
champ d'éoliennes qui est au large et
qui va libre et les batteries à
proximité dans les usines notamment au
nord de la france l'empreinte carbone
d'une telle usine est infiniment plus
faible qu'une usine du même des petits
frais par exemple en chine qui seraient
alimentés par de l'énergie venant de
charmants et qui ensuite seraient
transportés par des bateaux diesel
jusqu'en europe et donc comme la
priorité va être d'arriver à une
neutralité carbone en 2050 c'est-à-dire
demain pour arriver à cette neutralité
carbone le fait d'installer des
industries qui seront des années fric
décarbonés sur notre territoire est un
avantage compétitif important parce que
effectivement les bancs se retire de
plus en plus saison se retirer
totalement de toutes les énergies
carbonées pour une raison essentielle
c'est que tout ce qu'on appelle la
taxonomie qui est en train de se mettre
en place va tout simplement leur
interdire de le faire pour des raisons
de protection de la planète donc on a
une chance historique qui est à la fois
la transition écologique et la nécessité
de redonner une industrie du futur à
notre pays il faut qu'on saisisse cette
chance pour faire revenir des industries
en france nicolas babel a raison de dire
que pour le faire il faut une alliance
entre un système de formation qui doit
mieux préparer à l'emploi industriel est
un accueil dans les collectivités pour
que ces industries soit bienvenue et
bien acérées et cette année en scène est
en train de se faire sur les territoires
de mais juste un exemple sans être trop
long à venarey-les-laumes près de la
lésion c'est à dire au bâtiment une
dijon y avait une usine vallourec donc
pour les tubes sans soudure et cette
usine devait être transféré en
grande-bretagne pour des raisons de
compétitivité
et les dirigeants se sont rendus compte
que les savoir faire était très très
difficile à répliquer et que donc il y
avait plutôt intérêt à travailler sur
l'amélioration des processus mélusine
elle a été refaite à venarey-les-laumes
sur un terrain et dans des bâtiments qui
ont été financés par la caisse des
dépôts l'entreprise avait financé par bp
france et tout ça avec le soutien de la
région dont cette alliance allait me
mieux avec le soutien des collectivités
locales et elle a permis de maintenir un
site en france et d histoire
industrielle réussie
depuis quelques années il y en a de plus
en plus il faut le faire savoir il faut
l'encourager qui est intéressant avec
embarrassé vous vous appuyez à chaque
fois sur des exemples qui sont très
concrets laetitia on va parler du
nucléaire maintenant et vous avez
souhaité revenir sur le déplacement des
manuels macron à belfort c'était jeudi
dernier visite évidemment très
symbolique chez alstom oui je vais pas
parler du nucléaire je vais plutôt vous
parler ça va nous aider fils ou du
risque politique qu emmanuel macron
prenait en allant tabelles fort pour
finalement reprendre à generali tricks
la branche énergie d'alstom qui avait
été cédée en 2014 et pour la re donner à
edf c'est à dire pour les français qui
ne s'y connaissent pas vraiment et
comprennent que finalement ça revient
dans le giron français emmanuel macron y
va pour cela sauf qu'en 2014 fin 2014 il
est à bercy quand se finalise cet accord
est donc ils préparent ce déplacement
avec beaucoup de minutie puisqu'il
s'agit de faire oublier ou d'enterrer en
tout cas d'expliquer enfin ce qu'il
s'est passé en 2014 puisque les
américains avaient promis de créer 1000
emplois et sinon de donner cinquante
mille euros pour chaque emploi et 800
emplois ont été supprimés alors
évidemment les positions s'en est saisi
quelque assisté passé oui un flot de
critiques parce que c'était vraiment
simple c'est à dire que quand on a une
fenêtre comme ça idéal de critiques on y
va alors je vous incite une lune par
exemple sénateurs l air de côte-d'or à
la houpert macro ministre avait dépassé
le groupe alstom enfants dans la branche
équipements nucléaires macron président
l'a fait racheter par edf une manoeuvre
de bonneteau alors je rajouterais macron
président futur candidat parce qu'il ya
évidemment ça dans le calcul des manuels
macro et c'est pour ça qu'il est allé à
belfort à ce moment là il fallait pas
que ce soit trop rapprochées non plus du
premier tour parce que on ne savait pas
comment ça allait se passer et vraiment
il faut faire oublier cette image du
emmanuel macron qui vend aux américains
alstom alors il a commencé en disant
écoutez nous à la fin en 2014 parce que
sinon alstom mouret et ensuite leur
fasse vraiment aux
travailleurs il a repris un peu à son
habitude un son son bâton de pèlerin du
grand débat il s'est expliqué vraiment
un très proche d'eux écoutez je l' ai
vécu à l'époque c'était collaborateurs
quand ça s'est fait
de ce que j'ai vu non mais je pourrais
vous parler très franchement je dirais
pas qu'il ya eu des pressions il ya le
choix non mais moi je vous dit comment
je le
nom il ya eu beaucoup ce qui est normal
dans le cas des opérations comme ça il
ya toujours aussi beaucoup de
commentaires qui sont faits il ya des
choses qui sont vraies des choses qui
sont fausses alors emmanuel macron été
collaborateur c'est un mot qui est un
peu floue à dessein il était secrétaire
général adjoint au début du processus de
l'elysée au début du processus puis il
était à bercy à la suite d' arnaud
montebourg qu'il a suffisamment fait
savoir en tout cas kadhafi suffisamment
fait savoir son mécontentement
donc si vous voulez c'était un tout
petit peu délicat quand même comme
opération communication pour emmanuel
macron c'est de la communication
politique pure il était pour l'aider
avec jean pierre chevènement louis maire
de belfort pendant 20 ans qui a témoigné
ai dit c'est vrai qu'il n'était pas
vraiment aux commandes emmanuel macron
bon ça sortait les rames envoyé que
c'était quand même délicat à passer
pourquoi parce que c'est ce type de de
process économique quand on n'en
comprend pas vraiment les tenants et les
aboutissants qui marque la mémoire
collective pourquoi parce que des
familles sont touchées directement par
tonne par des pertes d'emplois et à deux
mois en tout cas à peu près trois mois
des élections présidentielles au moment
où il va et belfort c'est très compliqué
comme des placements union gas barioz
envoyé réagir
vous écrivez non pas du juge écrit pas
c'est un sujet que je connais plutôt
bien parce qu'on a étudié en commission
denquête avec olivier marc l'ex qui la
présidait en 2017 et moi j'en ai été le
rapporteur donc c'est un sujet sur
lequel on amélie si mal
on a revu énormément de personnes ont
pour faire le film dans tous les sens
depuis 2014 ce que nous on avait observé
dans notre commission denquête c'était à
l'époque que personne ne souhaitait
racheter la branche énergie d'alstom et
que le seul opérateur qui s'étaient
positionnés était de general electric
aucun acteur français ni même européen
ne voulait leur acheter que cette
opération l'amener je le rappelle par
une entreprise privée n'est pas une
entreprise d'état alstom doc été menée
était probablement à cette époque la
seule qui faisait 105 était possible et
que l a permis aussi dans le modèle
économique d'alstom transport cette
fois-ci de trouver une dynamique une
croissance et des choses positives pour
alstom transport donc
je peux refaire le film de l'histoire
depuis 2014 on peut refaire la
commission denquête qui compte c'est de
parler tout à l'heure de risques la fin
de l'histoire ce que je retiens de la
fin de l'histoire ce que je retiens moi
de l'histoire je faisais pas interrompu
tout à l'heure s'il vous plaît est ce
que moi je retiens de l'histoire c'est
d'une part vous l'avez dit qu' il n'y a
aucun sujet qui va sous le tapis c'est à
dire que le président il n'a pas honte
de ce qui s'est passé et il n'a pas peur
parce que la présidentielle arrive de ne
pas parler du sujet et il y va donc il a
bien pris effectivement le risque et il
a pris la mesure josé il ne met aucun
sujet sous le tapis et l'autre sujet que
je retiens c'est tout de même l'histoire
nucléaire qui est en train de se
construire c'est à dire une perspective
extrêmement optimiste et ambitieuse sur
la construction de nouveau opérée sur le
nucléaire en france pour une filière qui
est porteuse de croissance et qui nous
permet de décarbonés notre économie
alors ça que je retourne je retiens de
l'histoire mais ont pu refaire le film
dans tous les sens en 2014 du nucléaire
voilà c'est toujours
j'ai
donc d'abord deux choses sur alstom là
où c'est intéressant c'est que c'est le
retournement parce que ça démarre avec
pechiney donc si vous voulez les
fleurons entre pechiney lafarge toute
une série qu'on a laissé partir dans des
conditions
qui étaient sans doute beaucoup trop
rapide il y en a un paquet et ce qui est
intéressant c'est le retournement elle
retournement il se fait quand même parce
que je reviens ce qui s'est passé
pendant la pandémie on s'est aperçu que
être complètement dépendant de la chine
pour les biens essentiels des états unis
pour la technologie et entre nous soit
dit du financement pour l'allemagne
c'est quand même pas très sûr et donc il
vaut mieux changer sur le nucléaire je
pense que le là où on peut à la fois
accueillir positivement cette cette
décision mais en même temps la m quand
même un peu en recul et est en question
c'est que on parlait tout à l'heure de
déco système dont on sait tous
aujourd'hui que
le effectivement l'économie décarbonée
l'énergie c'est un facteur de production
déterminant il nous faut une énergie
décarbonée on sait que le bon mix et du
nucléaire et des renouvelables et que
l'abandon du nucléaire et la logistique
d'ailleurs c'est simple parce qu'il nous
faut de la base et donc l'abandon du
nucléaire qui a été la stratégie
implicite des dernières décennies c'est
une énorme erreur donc on l'a retourné
mais si vous voulez là où il ya une
question sait d'où vient l'argent c'est
quand même un programme à 50 milliards
d'euros qui n'est pas financé et on ne
peut pas annoncer ça en même temps qu on
déstabilise et le pivot de la filière
nucléaire qui est edf en en lui collant
donc pour une entreprise qui est déjà
surendettés un cadet de compétences en
allant lui m dos chargé du bien et
autres soucis qui est effectivement vous
l'avez dit c'est selon cbc on va écouter
françois bayrou sur ce thème le haut
commissaire au plan a été auditionné ici
même au au sénat le mois dernier
ni parler nucléaire écouter t'avais bien
le problème que nous avons aujourd'hui
dans les centrales nucléaires pour les
centrales nucléaires
c'est que ya
toute une génération de techniciens de
soudeur tout un savoir faire
qui s'est perdue pendant les quinze ou
vingt années où on a considéré que ceux
ci appartenait au passé
et si ça vous intéresse regarder le
documentaire de marion vidéo sur ce
thème les voilà le effectivement la
perte régulière de compétences dans le
secteur du nucléaire anaïs voix gili son
manque de soudeur alors c'est pas
seulement dans le nucléaire mais mais
moi je crois quand je vois ça pardon
c'est très basique mais on se demande
comment on a pu en arriver là est-ce que
c'est pas parce que on a arrêté par
exemple de répondre aux appels d'offres
étranger que on a les gouvernements les
différents pouvoirs politiques ont
changé pied sur le nucléaire et que donc
finalement quand on est un talent d'un
futur ingénieur aux images ne t'ai pas
les dents secteur puisqu'il n'y a pas de
volonté politique claire comment vous
l'analysez ça
juste une chose sur alstom ce qu'il faut
quelqu'un se fasse peut-être l'avocat du
diable un mois je pense qu'il faut
attendre quand même le périmètre du
rachat dans la branche énergie mais on
sait que les brevets sont partis dans
des filiales en suisse et j'ai deux
contrats de maintenance donc c'est pas
si évident que ça et la deuxième on peut
se poser la question en effet la
pertinence du rachat par edf
edf était un opérateur pour la
production d'électricité son métier
n'est pas d'être un industriel mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça sur les compétences
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'on a
vu dans toute l'industrie sert les
pénuries dont on parle dans le nucléaire
on le voit dans des dizaines et des
dizaines d'entreprises des entreprises
industrielles n'arrive pas à recruter
les profils qu'elle recherche et sur des
métiers très traditionnel la question de
la soudure c'est pas que dans le
nucléaire on retrouve aussi dans le dans
le naval et dans d'autres dans d'autres
secteurs je pensais deux choses 1 un
désintérêt pour ces secteurs ses terres
on a eu un discours très négatif
quelques discussions avec des ingénieurs
dans le nucléaire où ils ont presque
honte de dire à leurs amis qui
travaillent dans le nucléaire parce que
c'était un peu vu comme comme le diable
sert quand vous diaboliser tout un
secteur il faut pas s'étonner que
derrière les gens n'est pas forcément
envie d'aller y travailler et puis on a
arrêté de de former aussi pour ces
métiers puis on n'a pas fait de plans de
gestion des appels richelet gpc gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et des
compétences c'est-à-dire qu'on a
considérant qu'on n'avait pas forcément
besoin n'a pas renouvelé et sans le voit
aussi dans les semi-conducteurs qui est
un sujet européen bien sûr christian
salez dernier mot avec vous et eric
lombard peut-être sur le financement
nicolas baverez j'en parlais tout à
l'heure il ya vous vous l'avez évoqué la
taxonomie verte alors il faut dire c'est
au niveau européen c'est on va dire une
classification en fonction de l'impact
environnemental des secteurs et donc ça
permet de savoir où on flèche les
investissements européens et il ya eu
discussion bras de fer entre la france
l'allemagne et les autres pays
finalement le nucléaire et dans la
toponymie vers bon j'ai résumé ça très
rapidement est ce que ça veut dire que
le plan de financement il est il y là où
au contraire comme dit nicolas baverez
n'y aura pas les sous
d'abord c'est une excellente nouvelle ce
qui se passe c'est que l'une des raisons
de notre déficit commercial
c'est à cause de l'achat d'énergie et le
gaz le pétrole donc le fait d'avoir une
énergie domestique à partir du nucléaire
du renouvelable c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour le pays pour la balance commerciale
et les compétences c'est évidemment un
sujet mais c'est un sujet qui peut se
traiter avec des pays france on a fait
un appelé le lit tour
pour aller vendre les métiers
industriels sur l'ensemble des
territoires ça marche très très bien les
jeunes sont prêts la seconde à venir
pourquoi aller très vite le financement
l'épargné française est extrêmement
abondante dans les fonds n'est pas géré
par la caisse des dépôts il ya plus de
300 milliards d'euros qui finance le
logement social mais aussi qui peut
financer la réindustrialisation les
parades française est abondante et donc
le financement de ce programme qui n'est
pas encore complètement défini entre ce
qui relèvera du capital du financement
de l' épargne populaire et autres mais
pas calé mais notre pays est un pays
d'epargne sais la chance que nous avons
c'est que dans ces cas ne jamais
interrompre je suis désolé mais le débat
est terminé c'est très c'est très mal
poli de ma part mais voilà j'ai obligé
de vous interromps vous étiez le dernier
intervenant merci beaucoup eric lombard
pour me faire pardonner je cite le titre
de votre livre au coeur de la finance
utile à quoi sert votre épargne c'est
aux éditions de l'observatoire anaïs
gillis vers la renaissance industriel
chez marie b nicolas baverez
reconstruction au pluriel aux édition de
l'observatoire également